so let's go to 911
you're 14 years old the event takes
place it happens
um you know you're watching the news
and names come up osama bin laden
your next last name is bin laden what
what are you thinking in that moment
what's your mother's reaction what are
your two older sisters reaction when you
see that even taking place
so before all of that happens
um and we haven't touched upon this yet
but
people i mean your viewers um
don't know this but i am a total patriot
at heart
like america after switzerland is my
second home
the love for america was passed on to me
by my mother who really valued what the
country was built on
and she started taking me to the u.s two
to three times a year from the age of
three whenever i'd have school holidays
so by the time i reached 14 years old
america
was my second home um so much so that
you know two years before 9 11 i had
gotten a u.s
flag on holiday in south carolina and it
was you know
on my wall in my room and i would get
teased so much in school i went to an
international school
here in switzerland and i get teased so
much for being such a patriot
even though i didn't hold a u.s
citizenship
and
the day 9 11 happened it was the it was
my second day in school we just started
classes again
and we're six hours ahead right so i
came out of school
and um
the attacks had already happened and my
mom
came to pick me up with my eldest sister
in the car and
we rushed home my other sister met us
there
and we were all devastated um
we were watching the news i was
sobbing uncontrollably it felt that
someone had attacked
my home and
i was in utter shock and disbelief at
what i was watching
and you know just the sheer violence and
thinking of the people who were there
and suffering it was
i mean everybody in the world remembers
where they were
that day and was shocked you know by
by what happened um and
that you know completely is the same for
me and and
this this special place that america
has in my heart made it even more you
know
horrible um and devastating to me
and watching the news what happened is
that my mother
the moment the second plane hit
she knew because as i had said she'd
been following you know all the events
leading up to that and she knew he
wasn't going to stop
but she never imagined it would
something like this or
of this magnitude nobody could compute
something like this
would happen but so the moment the
second plane hit
she knew that our name was going to be
linked right
so after the
the initial you know the first moments
where we were just
all grieving in front of the television
she you know
sat us down the three of us and told us
you know girls you know brace yourselves
because your life is never going to be
the same again
and a couple of hours later that's when
the name
started um started circulating
and well what she said uh happened
you know and did you go when did you go
to school next day and if you did how
did the teachers how did everybody react
when they saw you what did they say
um i went to school the next day and um
people knew how much i loved
uh america because of i was you know
quite well known in the school and quite
popular i was
one of the star athletes of the school
and they knew how much america you know
means to me and so they were very very
kind
they came to me asking me if i was okay
and um people were very kind to me the
next day and very lovely
wow that's great to hear powerful
because they knew your true beliefs now
what did your mom get her belief system
who who passed down
their belief system to your mom or did
she have an inspiration did she read a
book did she have somebody that inspired
her
well her mom you know the way she was
raised also by her
her mom and she i think set a great
example for her and
but my mom was also very rebellious from
my understanding also you know growing
up
and she always loved she always
loved freedom she has this streak you
know for freedom and that's why you know
she really wanted to go to america
and then when she moved there with my
father um
almost immediately they met this this
lady
um marry martha
[Music]
my mom talks a lot about her in the book
and she kind of became her second
mom she'd call her my american mom
marry martha and so i think you know
these two women had um
had a big impact in her in her life and
you know although we didn't grow up with
a
religion you know and my mother didn't
grow up with a religion
either she saw my grandmother pray you
know in
synagogue in a church in the mosque so
that's how she were
she was raised and we weren't raised
with a definite religion
either growing up the three of us but
very much with judeo-christian values
[Music]
and
[Music]
yeah the appreciation for the western
the western way and ideals
um is something that has you know been
present very much in both my mother's
life and my life as well
you